because we got into this comfort zone
behavior hundreds of years our genetics
have changed our physiology has changed
everything has changed
and we lost actually the full power of
the mind and I'm here to bring it back
what a sore get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best wim hof and how to develop the
Iceman's mindset and become superhuman
meant to me win what is it about what
you do that triggers the adaptation
response and what adaptation response
doesn't trigger the power to adapt to
this stressor in general we lost this
connection is because we wear clothes
all the time and we live in a comfort
zone behavior we think we can control
nature but by being non stimulative in
our behavior we lost the connection in
the depth of our physiology cause we are
able to add that about to anything we
are built to be able to adapt without
stress into any stressful situation
again a solution the body knows but
because we got into this comfort zone
behavior hundreds of years our genetics
have changed our physiology has changed
everything has changed and we lost
actually the full power of the mind and
I'm here to bring it back how do we
bring it back I did many studies already
because I don't like this speculation I
go through study this scrutiny and let
any scientist prove me wrong because I
like to go through the truth because I
think there is more than meets the eye I
did many studies and yes I could resist
the bacteria as thought of not being
able over by humans
we changed medical history by showing a
group of people compared to 16,000 134
people becoming sick after injection of
a endotoxemia and then suddenly 1200
percent score within a quarter of our
complete control over the innate immune
system and is specific by the way the
adaptive immune system and how did I
learn to do that and pass it on
because it's already there in us it only
needs to awaken the finally adaptive
immune system the adaptive immune system
is willfully regulating and controlling
your t-cells and b-cells and they are
located in the bone marrow we are able
to willfully influence the bone marrow
and to release the T and beta B cells
which are very specific in the targeting
on the bacteria and the virus and
apoptosis cell death
they created instead of fever and
uncontrolled shivering and and headaches
and being sick flus fever and all that
is the second layer we got into the
third layer into the depth of the immune
system into the deepest so willfully
being able to get into the bone marrow
and release the T and B cells in case of
inflammation is what we an inflammation
I tell you is the course of any disease
did you just say that you can willfully
control apoptosis yes anybody can okay
for that we have the breathing exercises
and it has been shown in the comparative
study all the guys who did their
breathing exercises the end of Toxie
normally creates inflammation and thus
uncontrolled shivering all over agony
headaches and fever and the people
really get sick after injected being
injected with the bacteria e.coli and
that's normal but it was not normal to
be able to inoculate that reaction how
did we do that by breathing exercises
that are like controlled hypoxia where
through the brain stem the fight and
flight suddenly activates the adrenaline
and resets the body and resetting the
body is going past our comfort zone
conditioning going back in our
primordial state the way nature Manor to
be and that is being able effectively to
battle this is very simple very
effective very accessible for any
in the world and that we go a step
further a Stepford is the last study
we're in I was exposed to cold water and
just by a thought I was able to make the
skin temperature not going down well I
was exposed to cold water on my skin ice
water
your skin temperature done done yes and
normally it goes down that is what
everybody thinks isn't it and yes 74
people before me they did it and they
saw all the same graphics it goes down
after exposure to cold water and when
warm water comes up then it goes up
again and goes down called walk o walk
call walk and then I did it same I
didn't do anything
why because I'm in command of my breath
and with that I become a in command of
my alchemy and I'm able then to scent
and to manipulate any part of my body
they looked inside the brain and whereas
normally stress comes to work on the
body and that could be called could be
heat but could also be emotion
depression bipolar anxiety fear PT a
PTSD trauma it's all stress in the brain
and it gets inflamed and we don't know
how to break the loop now they looked
inside of my brain while this stressor
was gone on and I stayed out of
de-stresser when the call came in I just
stayed over there and a warmth called
wolf I stay in control and then they
looked inside the brain and whereas
normally the activity of the stress is
highlighting the prefrontal cortex the
conscious brain because it's cold
oh I feel bad because I'm divorced now
and this and that and my business is
gone and whatever you know stress real
stress and that the insula which is
normally active very activated when you
go into
meditation then the insula gets a is
becoming more rat and then this is blue
because deactivates the normal daily
consciousness and the insula the deep
meditation is oh and blood flow goes in
the deeper parts of the brain suddenly
becomes all active and its pleasant it's
nice before ik if you go into here to
the eyes you're really not thinking
about your mortgage or your wife or this
or that
you are not going to picnic you feel the
focus will be on your feeling how to get
this feeling into adaptation and to
overcome whatever is coming and it goes
directly in a I tell you they the cold
has been my teacher I just followed the
teacher the feeling learned to let go
intuitively I felt I want to do this I
did yoga did come food it or all kinds
of things and and great but the cold is
really merciless but righteous and I was
ready to go in I felt intuitively I want
to go in because it has got something I
don't know what it is and yes I went in
and I felt it the connection was there
beyond any word and that's what I was
looking for this tapping into deeper
part of the brain feeling pure energy
feeling our innate capacity the power we
have to deal with that I was looking for
that and since then I went on and on and
on I know I did all these records and
many more challenges I did crazy stuff
really sitting all the night in your
shorts outside in freezing temperatures
and feel great that is something that is
power and I've been venturing and
discovering more and more and finally I
began to realize but it's all in the
mind
oh yes so learning to let go in the
right way following your breath the
breath is able to prime the body and
then your mind and all
of the mind if I'm able to make my skin
temperature not going down well being
exposed to ice-cold water skin
temperature that's power and that power
is the same power we can learn to
embrace and awaken in which we are able
to tackle any stressor in the world any
stressor emotionally and physically and
mentally whatever here you come up we
are built to be able to oppose that to
get through and to learn and not to be
afraid because we have the power of the
mind it seems like there's two things to
your method number one is the breath so
what I want to know is when you're
breathing in the way that you're
breathing which there's a lot of great
video on there that will link to in the
show notes so when you're breathing like
that why do you think that allows you to
begin to reconnect to something that
everyone will call the autonomic system
meaning that you don't have conscious
control over how does that link it yes
very simple these breathing techniques
I've learned to do in extreme cold so
they are stream lis effective very soon
I was able to stay and prolong my time
in ice water feeling great but is the
breath just about oxygenating the
tissues oxygenating not only to go past
in this case to go past the lymphatic
knots which normally inhibits the oxygen
to go deeper now we found a way to go
past these knots into the lymphatic
system and with that you come into the
depth of your body and making you able
to alkalize your blood within a couple
of minutes with that a when the blood is
the right pH degree then suddenly the
neurology of the mind which is like
electricity is able to run through on a
subtle basis so actually we are mammals
we are about you know we are built after
millions of years as mammals
if your geology is inside the wiring and
every
is inside and three times the world's
length is vascular systems inside of us
killer number one in our society is
cardiovascular related it's big time and
that is because we wear clothes we are
never being a stammer
stimulated through cold warm and
pressure it's no longer there so there
is a mediocre state of our vascular
conditioning and that and for that we
take cold showers then there's some
shock to the system that is Haram Isis
or we do it consciously and with that we
connect even with the brain with the
vascular system all over and it's
amazing how simple it can be how simple
we contact tackle this serial killer
their cardiovascular related diseases we
can tackle in a cold shower a day keeps
the doctor away I want to go back to
when you're 17 yes
the ice water starts calling to you and
also part of what makes us fascinating
is you have an identical twin yes so one
it's fascinating that you guys took very
divergent paths so if I understand right
you've begun to teach him your method
yes but when you're there at the water
and it's calling to you what what is
that like it's 17 I know you'd been
searching searching for like I need this
this whatever this is I need it all to
make sense I need to connect to a God or
something to fill me up to let me
connect to something bigger than myself
so yeah you have that calling I don't
know what but it is there and it is
inside of me and it's more than meets
the eye and all that and it made me at
age of 12 study psychology and going
into Hinduism Buddhism and all kinds of
esoteric disciplines and when I was 17
ugh I just had this feeling and my twin
brother who's identical is not able to
do only after my training to come up
with the results because it's not
genetical it is trained and so this one
is able to be trained by any body
fact that you're an identical twin it's
like you're the perfect subject I mean
it's literally crazy you have an
identical twin to be like the the
perfect control subject yes yes
absolutely
it's like hundred percent genetical
score match and he is not able to do it
and I'm not and I'm able to do it so
they did certain kinds of experiments
and they saw this in scientific
environment that I was able to do things
and he could not and the later when I
trained him he was able to do about the
same Jesus that's that's extraordinary
we all are able to battle inflammation
to have a control top down in our body
much more than we thought possible at
least to be able to guarantee happiness
strength and health which is all related
to hormones and the control of the
immune system and nervous system now
I've got a special bonus on how to
change your chemistry that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go
question number one how will you find
your inner strength number two what will
you do this week to take steps towards
it and number three who can hold you
accountable to make sure that you stay
consistent on it if we just breathe more
deeply change the chemistry inside not
shallow breathing deep breathing slowly
but surely
this is what you do consciously you do
this 30 times the chemistry in the body
in the tissue is changing and it's
changing so that the body is becoming ox
energized alkaline and then suddenly the
brain-body connection is possible by
pressurizing by
[Music]
once you begin to have that connection
with the body then you are able to
connect within in the brain and that's
what we do right now with Stanford
University to get rid of PTSD fear
trauma and depression to learn to expand
consciousness and together with
breathing you create the right chemistry
and then the neurons they channel up and
thus your perception your consciousness
is gonna be you smell more you see their
colors brighter you experience deeper
and that's the brain and then connecting
once again with all the cells makes you
a beautiful living being if you want
more wim hof check out the event that I
went to and filmed with him one on one
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there are a lot of stuff outside
in nature because I felt this
disconnection from nature inside from
the soul itself
[Music]